but even in the social network the guy
that plays them seems very like like
alien yeah uh what was his name uh the
actor who played him yeah Michael
Michael Sarah
it's the guy that's like Michael Sarah
though
[Music]
ripped bartis yeah this photo's going
around I'm sure yeah what's that oh my
god dude Mark sucked oh yeah Marky is
jacked I know he's pretty buff is it
true I think he's fighting Elon at UFC
230 or so are they really gonna do that
I just saw a post that it's going down
it's next year March I thought elon's
Mom called it off
but is it do you think it's matched well
because he's so tall like elon's tall
bigger and then Zuck is like smaller but
ripped yeah yeah I think it's a good
match though who you got who do you
think's gonna win of course you know
Zach's gonna win yeah you think so yeah
because he he was between on a Jujitsu
or something yeah he's been training
yeah but but is is Elon training I don't
think anyone training bro
Elon came down and he said when he
rolled with him he was surprised he was
actually surprised at his athletes
athleticism and his natural like ability
even though he's big and fat that's what
that's what that's three months and the
next room is a BJJ black belt oh well I
guess he just had to smothers okay guys
that's why right doesn't Psy still play
a big role it's 58 yeah yeah but but
then I thought in UFC you have different
weight levels yeah yeah the size
difference is too big but like in the
UFC it was a sanctioned fight I don't
think that would normally happen but I
think there could be an exception to be
made because it's the spectacle isn't
seeing who's the best at this weight
class it's like seeing who's the best
billionaire yeah or text billion
millionaire at fighting did you find out
if it's going down like for sure like
UFC 230 or something as of July 12th an
exhibition agreement between musk and
Zuckerberg has yet to materialize um
maybe it's on the table and they haven't
yet shook hands on it yeah this is going
to be is probably the the highest rated
match it has to be history that is so
cool though in history yeah we're
actually gonna wear a uh a Thrust
t-shirt today yeah a threads t-shirt
Twitter and threats Lilo has a Twitter
that would be so cool though because
they they the stakes are they can
use or like run the other person's
social media platform for 24 hours and
do whatever they want that's cool is
that what the challenge is well that's
what Elon suggested I mean elon's are
saying all kinds of crazy stuff yeah
elon's a big [__] talker yeah I know I
think he's a troll yeah do we do any of
us know or does the public even know
what his training experience is because
I've recently we've seen Zuckerberg yeah
train right but I'm like dude did Elon
do Judo as a kid or like you know that's
true you never know there's all these
undercover people like that guy salt
poppy oh yeah like they people call them
out and they think oh he's just learning
a fight for social media fights but he's
like dude I've been boxing since I was
five yeah go ahead and call me but then
people think like oh he was a nurse for
this many years until yeah so it's like
who knows what people have done yeah
yeah but I I watched the UFC fights
really close to the uh octagon yeah I
can't watch it the second time oh
and some of them are just really big you
know I I interviewed a champion actually
his name is Anthony or something from
Brazil
he basically I told Neo Silva Antonio
good guess is he
ugly like Bigfoot Silva right yeah yeah
well he was hit by a truck when he was
10. oh no no no he's
ugly too
but more more handsome you're gonna make
him answer that you know if I have your
muscle I can't say that yeah
but when I met him I because I actually
he told me he was hit by a truck at 10.
I just asked him so who won
it was so
twin brother or a bear yeah oh there's
another one that looks just like him oh
wow and they have the same name I think
yeah they they go by nog this is the
last is legera so there's like little
nog and big nog but I think even little
nag is like six three wow damn so
they're just two big dudes so yeah as
far as it has gone uh like you had
mentioned on July 3rd photos of must
training with UFC Legend George Saint
Pierre uh and MMA coach John down her
and Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt like
Alex Friedman surface online with an IG
post from St Pierre showing the four men
and training gear but must biographer
Walter Isaacson later claimed in a
Twitter space session that he doubted a
fight would happen and that it was a
metaphor for the competition between the
CEO's rivaling social media sites
threads and Twitter I want to see it go
down I want to see a metaphor I want to
see them grapple which at the end of the
day it's pretty [__] hilarious
marketing though like the head of
threads and the head of Twitter that are
both I'll say this like bro when I first
started doing any martial art like this
I never thought MMA would be as big as
it is now and to see the two biggest
billionaires and the two biggest names
in the game doing Jiu Jitsu
it's like making it mainstream where
people are talking about it is crazy
yeah like it's so crazy to me and it's
it's good for business though it's good
for the gym
I mean I just remember David so's post
talking about being pissed off at Mark
Zuckerberg's ripped hahaha bro he's
jacked he is he's he's not just rev he's
jacked bro like he is in good shape was
it isn't it funny because I think um
Elon called him out to fight before
threads came out and then feds came out
right yeah that's true so do you think
Elon knew about that so that was the
whole metaphor behind the fight because
it's like you want to go I bet they know
Elon doesn't know
this says uh the idea of a cage match
was first posed by musk over Twitter
where the Tesla CEO responded to a
thread about Instagram's then upcoming
rival rival app thread saying I'm up for
a cage match if he is so I think it was
just on the cusp of and about threads
anyway coming out you know what's pretty
crazy about the Zuck stuff though is
like before he had all these pictures of
him doing MMA he I don't think he was
really like that well liked like nobody
really was like oh he's cool but now
since he's training with all these UFC
champs he's cool now dude like I think
he's cool it's a good repair for like
what he did during that interview
remember when they had they had like the
Supreme Court yeah the Supreme Court one
and he seemed like a total robot oh yeah
yeah I remember that yeah now he's back
to being relatable his approval rating
is through the roof yeah yeah people
love this guy now I never thought he was
like alien or something yeah all you had
to do was take a shirt off yeah but even
in the social network the guy that plays
him seems very like like aliens yeah uh
what was his name uh the actor who
played him yeah Michael's Michael Sarah
it's the guy that's like Michael Sarah
though Jonah Hill yeah another nervous
dude I think he was in Zombieland yeah
his name Eisenberg or something yeah
yeah Eisenberg Jesse Eisenberg
Heisenberg but it's hard to think of him
because you always think Mark Zuckerberg
when you see his face yeah oh he's
always he's always going to be the Zuck
dude I want to see Joe Biden Robert F
Kennedy dude I want to see Joe Biden and
DeSantis I think Robert of King said
what
do you think Biden will even understand
what's happening RFK is so jacked yeah
dude bite is not gonna make the walk bro
it's a long walk from the locker room to
the to the cage bro that's cruel at that
point some guys start running from the
the from the locker room yeah you think
Biden will do that he will do that too I
wonder what his walk out song would be
oh yeah well it would be the [__]
Anthem bro it should be the national
anthem
everyone's about the same yeah even
Trump even if he reaches the Octagon he
can't climb in there
yeah
that's just mean yeah
when you did the White House did you
meet any big politicians and stuff oh
yeah yeah like Harry read you know uh
Gary Locke
uh and there are a lot of them because
the 2400 people in the audience wow I
know yeah just a lot of uh media people
along with police Blitzer yeah yeah did
you meet uh President Obama at the time
he was supposed to be there but in two
weeks before the show you know they're
like oh he couldn't make it but the vice
president is going to be there which was
Biden so you met Joe Biden yeah yeah oh
wow did he smell your hair when he shook
your hand oh no no because I I'm a guy
you know I said what are you talking
about
[Laughter]
but you know at the time I think the
death of his uh elderly son really did a
number on him yeah before his son died
he was a lot more conscious because you
know so oh yeah more present you have
more present yeah that's the word yeah
you're two in one joke really he seemed
to like it though oh yeah good that was
good thanks
yeah but yeah he's a well he's a pretty
good sport I have to say now afterwards
he would just come up to me and say oh
Joe uh
years later if I go to your house and
your people tell you that Joe Biden's
outside please don't just say uh who
did the Callback on my previous year
that's cool there's actually listening
the whole time oh yeah he was listening
he wasn't senile yet
[Music]
all right